tech giants are celebrating
record-breaking sales this morning
Amazon 60 and a half billion dollars in
fourth quarter revenue was much higher
than expected sales are up 38% on the
previous year fourth-quarter sales of
Google's parent company alphabet
exceeded 32 billion dollars up 24% and
apples revenue topped 88 billion dollars
profits hit 20 billion for the first
time the three companies combined made
more than half a trillion dollars last
year CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is with us good morning Jill
Wow okay let's start with Amazon why are
things better than expected well as we
know they are expanding beyond just
online so that's really interesting we
also know that Amazon derives an
enormous amount of money from their
cloud computing area it drives revenue
like crazy was a forty five percent from
a year ago it's just incredible we know
that holiday sales better than expected
and by the way a little interesting
factoid 789 million dollars in a tax
benefit due to the tax law changes so
they took that in the fourth quarter
there would have been profitable anyway
but an amazing result does that really
help them do you think these companies
are getting too big too dominant well
you know there's a case to be made for
that if you look at just how search is
done we know Google accounts for 90% of
search or something like that and
spending you put together Facebook plus
Google and you know that AB dollars
almost two-thirds of every $1 spent it
goes to one of those two companies and I
think that there's this case that people
are saying they're just getting too big
they're too dominant when you talk to
antitrust lawyers what they say is you
know what the consumer is the focus when
it comes to antitrust and consumers are
not harmed by the dominance of these
companies and that's the key let's dig
into the numbers for Apple because this
was the first earnings report since the
release of their new phone lackluster
sales so how did they recover you know
it's a beautiful thing when you can
charge more that will make up for your
lackluster sales so that thousand-dollar
iPhone X which no no I've not bought yet
but that made up for a lot I will say
there was a couple of things interesting
about this report one is they gave
disappointing guidance in the future and
a lot of the analysts that I spoke to
said that wasn't expected the other
piece of this don't forget apples
on about 250 two billion dollars
overseas they're going to repatriate
that 38 billion dollars they're gonna
pay in taxes they got to do something
with that money so it's gonna be
research development and I suspect
they're going to be looking for some
tasty acquisitions all right you didn't
get the iPhone ten but a lot of people
do it I know that okay yeah all right
Thank You Jill